[Musique]
vous me tenez j'arrive pas à la mettre
en face
il me tenez la chaîne une seconde c'est
tout Monsieur Merci vous êtes bien bien
urbains tenez mettez vous là vous tenez
bien la chaîne pour que j'appuie sur la
trapper allez-y monsieur pardon
monsieur si vous m'aidez pas jamais à
moi était déjà à vous maintenant pour
l'instant non il ne tient qu'à vous
qu'elle soit à moi vous m'aidez oui ou
non merde enfin monsieur vous êtes
malhonnête vous m'avez dit oui tiens
monsieur vous voulez pas m'aider à
décoincer la chaîne merde quoi merci
monsieur vous la tirez bien
ah oui coupé
c'est à moi monsieur la moto elle est à
moi si vous m'aidez
des flics des blaireaux nos amis les
bêtes vous les regardez vous surveillez
comme ça je tire la bécane
allez et en même temps tu regardes s'il
y a les flics qui viennent regarde un
peu mais attends mais [ __ ]
je te crois pas ça le sang jeune mais
viens [ __ ] salon vendu de l'autre côté
du Maillon voilà
les clés de j'ai pas de clé pour ça
monsieur c'est pas moi
alors quoi Monsieur attention les trucs
pour venir mais vous cassez pas
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu